l'été approche ce sera bientôt la saison
des climatiseurs ils refroidissent les
édifices mais rejette aussi de la
chaleur à l'extérieur ce qui pose un
problème dans les zones urbaines
un chercheur de québec a trouvé une
solution pour séquestrer cette chaleur
sous terre
[Musique]
le secteur d'estimauville à québec est
en pleine transformation
au milieu des chantiers de toutes sortes
celui de jacques maire raymond passent
presque inaperçus ces deux forages dans
un terrain vague ne vont pas servir à
puiser de l'eau mais de la fraîcheur
l'eau souterraine et à petits degrés
celsius
hiver comme été idéale climatiser les
bâtiments sans réchauffer le quartier
[Musique]
les climatiseurs conventionnelle vont
racheter l'achat dans cet air chaud là
va contribuer à garder la température de
l'air en milieu urbain de 1 à 2 degrés
celsius plus chaud et particulièrement
pendant la nuit et la nuit c'est le
moment où les jeunes vont retrouver un
peu de fraîcheur et où les stress
thermique petit minutes donc l'intérêt
de climatiser avec l'énergie au
thermique c'est de retourner cette
chaleur twitter pour essayer de diminuer
un peu l'effet de la chaleur
on peut déjà climatisé grâce à la
géothermie mais règle générale c'est en
boucle fermée
un mélange d'eau et d'antigel circulent
dans une série de tuyaux pour
s'imprégner de la fraîcheur du sol puis
remonte pour climatiser un bâtiment
avant de retourner sous ten
c'est un système plus cher à installer
que la boucle ouverte où l'eau froide
présente dans le sol
pompey d'un côté circulent dans le
bâtiment absorbent la chaleur puis
retourne dans le sol un peu plus loin
l'idée du suzel aussi terne c'est qu'on
peut fournir un bâtiment avec moins de
deux forages donc répondre à la demande
énergétique avec un système qui est
moins dispendieux par complicité mans
que l'on s'unisse directement l'eau
souterraine sont limités à des endroits
où il ya un potentiel intéressant
[Musique]
le site des forages n'a pas été choisie
au hasard
on savait qu'en creusant 25 mètres on
tomberait sur une ancienne plage il y à
des milliers d'années à l'époque la mer
de champlain le sable et les fragments
de coquillages se sont accumulés ici des
grains assez gros qui facilite le
pompage de l'eau
c'est ce qu'on appelle un aquifère
sous la basse ville de québec la couche
de sable est très épaisse et contient
donc beaucoup d'eau
la peinture jaune c'est d'extension du
complexe et différent et et les couleurs
je montre en fait l'épaisseur ce qui est
intéressant pour le col et udcy dans la
ville de québec c'est que là où il ya le
plus grand potentiel à qui faire mais ça
correspond également aux chiens endroits
où il ya des problématiques du coach à
leur bien en fait
le site du projet aki froid est entourée
de béton de route et dim en
stationnement qui retiennent la chaleur
et les climatiseurs traditionnel
amplifie le problème
jasmin est raymond crois que l'acquis
faire peut fournir la solution pour le
vérifier on simule l'effet de la
climatisation en prélevant de l'eau
froide d'un côté et on l'a réchauffant
avec un brûleur au propane
avant de la retourner dans le sol
[Musique]
l'équipe de lee nrs va suivre à la trace
comment l'eau chaude se dispersent des
thermomètres placés dans des puits
d'observation prennent des mesures en
continu
on fait aussi circuler un courant
électrique dans le sol plus l'eau est
chaude et mieux le courant passe
ça permet donc de voir le panache de
chaleur grandir à mesure que l'eau
chaude est injectée à la fin du test
la chaleur se dissipe peu à peu c'est
notamment parce que l'eau froide se
déplacent naturellement dans le sol des
régions en altitude au nord vers le
fleuve au sud
les premiers résultats sont donc
encourageants d'autant que l'eau
injectée pendant les tests est plus
chaude que celle qui sortirait d'un vrai
système de climatisation
on veut mesurer des changements dans
l'aquifère qui aurait lieu pendant une
vingtaine d'années d'opération d'un
système de combat charge automne et oui
où on a eu des surprises
pour notre premier test on a eu lieu à
des problématiques de colmatage
directement le laps de temps qu'on a
fait notre test ces taches orange
trahissent le coupable
les particules de fer ont bloqué les
tuyaux plus rapidement que prévu
pour comprendre pourquoi on récolte de
l'eau à différentes profondeurs
tout au fond
l'eau est riche en fer quand on la
réchauffe et qu'elle se mélangent à
l'eau de surface qui contient de
l'oxygène le faire s'oxydent et forme de
petits grains pire encore certaines
bactéries deviennent hyper active et
accélère cette réaction chimique
le côté scientifique pour nous c'est
intéressant parce qu'on s'intéresse à
cette problématique là et on veut
comprendre pourquoi c'est arrivé
pour tenter de développer des méthodes
là pour le prévenir à faire puisque ces
essais un des freins principal au
développement des systèmes géothermiques
à beaucoup vers l'arrivée des nouvelles
méthodes pour réduire cette
problématique là qui ont un impact en
bout de ligne sur la performance des
systèmes ajouté
[Musique]
c'est un des obstacles qu'il faudra
surmonter pour déployer la technologie
dans le secteur dont québec veut faire
un éco quartier et d'autres villes
pourraient s'en inspirer
toronto winnipeg et vancouver ont elles
aussi à la fois les problèmes d'îlots de
chaleur et une solution climatisation
sous les clics
en fait on en retrouve à différents
endroits au canada mais maintenant c'est
des ressources qui sont vraiment méconnu
peu étudiée et dont le potentiel n'est
pas pleinement exploité tout l'intérêt
de le promouvoir via des travaux de
recherche comme on s'aime
jasmin raymond s'est donné pour mission
de démocratiser la géothermie est le
meilleur moyen d'y arriver c'est de la
rendre toujours plus efficaces et
abordables
[Musique]